children at work
their numbers are increasing in a
country where a worsening economic
crisis is pushing more people into
poverty
nearly eight in ten people in lebanon
are now poor nearly half of the
workforce is unemployed those who still
have jobs struggle because of the
collapse in the value of the local
currency
for many like majid abdullah this means
having to decide whether to send their
children to school
i have five children two of the
teenagers don't go to school any longer
they work at a hair salon and a cafe to
help us pay bills
they are among the victims of lebanon's
economic collapse and skyrocketing
inflation that has particularly affected
children
a recent study by the un's child agency
unicef shows
3 in 10 households have cut spending on
education
four in ten have been forced to sell
household items to buy basic goods
seven in ten have had to buy food on
credit or using borrowed money
the united nations says living
conditions have deteriorated
dramatically in just a few months with
more children going to bed hungry and
not receiving the health care they need
i never seen a child who was
malnourished
in this country before but recently i
witnessed by myself a child who is
really suffering from the
malnutrition
so
those desperate mothers and
who are being
forced to take
desperate measures
only because they need to survive
omar dalile is among them this vegetable
seller used to be able to support his
family before the financial meltdown
began two years ago
not any longer
that means ali zhen and hulud are among
what the u.n says are the 260 000
children of school age whose education
is at risk their father tells us the
priority is to feed them
i can't send them to school every day
because i don't make enough to give them
pocket money or to buy the books
stationary and all other items they need
it
hundreds of thousands of children are
already living without the basic needs
being met and the lack of political will
to change a system that has inflicted
misery on the population means the
crisis is set to worsen senator al
jazeera beirut